you know um i know how close you and
jared are and i love the guy and i know
you're gonna direct a walker episode
coming up coming up so i'll we'll talk
about that but you know i know that
there was that you and daniel created a
you know a an idea to do a prequel for
supernatural right and it was written
about and then jared posted online that
he you know this is the first i've heard
about it and he was a little bit upset
yeah how did that go about um it was
well
for most for those who know me know that
i'm i'm
extremely superstitious when it comes to
a few things and one of those is
and this is probably something that that
a lot of actors shares like we don't
talk about auditions until we got the
role 100
you know yeah i i learned that very
quickly when i'd call mom and dad back
home
and they'd be like
what are you working on and be like oh
i'm going out for this one audition and
i've got this other audition for this
show and
my mom still asked me if i got saving
private ryan see yeah it's like no yeah
my mom is like over did you hear about
pearl harbor are you did you get it it's
like it was you know 15 years ago ma no
no it's not happening right right so i i
this you know something
people who aren't in the industry may
may not understand but it is it is just
simply something that it's an unwritten
rule that you just you don't talk about
[ __ ] until
until it's a done deal until the ink is
dried
and
this was my first venture into
uh producing and and creating content uh
and
i i didn't i didn't want to jinx it at
any cost so i'd shut up divulge any
information to anybody so i shut up
about it only the people that had to
know knew
and i wasn't trying to keep it a secret
for any other purpose other than than
superstition right um
i just i'm like if i don't talk about it
i got a better chance of this happening
right and
i i definitely
had people that i was you know excited
to tell
uh jared being
number one on that list
uh mom being number two sorry mom
um
and uh
and then and then it it it was getting
close to getting to the point where it
was like oh this is really happening the
network the studio had signed off on it
now the network was was getting involved
uh we still didn't have a script in fact
we just got the script last week wow so
this was back in february or something
so it was very early on i mean we had a
concept essentially
and uh
you know when you start getting studio
and you start getting network involved
you start getting a lot of people a lot
of eyes in a lot of years there's
assistance there's you know publicists
there's executives and people talk and
and it got out and you know deadline has
they've got moles everywhere right you
know he probably works for deadline ryan
ryan
deadline do you want the [ __ ]
deadline dude
he's over here taking extensive notes
i've noticed it's different today yeah
it's yeah it's my deadline look it's
your deadline
this is this is what this is what a
deadline yeah this is this is what a
deadline is the deadline template
this is what a mole looks like
all right so they so they they they
dropped they you know i'm on set in
toronto and i get a phone call that
they're like hey deadline uh caught wind
of it and they're they're throwing
something out this afternoon i was like
what so
i quickly had to like write up a little
something uh and i'm getting called from
uh network and i'm getting called from
studio
you know head of pr at warner brothers
and i'm getting call from my agent my
manager and like everybody and i'm like
running back and forth to set and i'm on
a new set and they don't do cell phones
on this set right which is just
something that the i like that yeah i do
too i have no problem with it but
and they also stay on set
right so there's they just sit they sit
there all day long the actors
and they they stay off the the social
media and the phones and stuff so if you
need to make a phone call or you need to
check something you got to go back out
to the trailers which
is sometimes they're far you which
sometimes are far but it's also you know
it's slightly frowned upon right and i'm
the new guy and i don't want to like
ruffle feathers like i'm a guest in this
these people's house so i'm gonna play
by their rules
so
i go back and i look at my phone and i'm
like trying to come up with a
you know a little blurb
uh that i can send out
to you know like hey we're deadline boom
excited
all the while not even thinking like oh
[ __ ] i haven't told
abcde or you know
i i haven't like
and that that was something that i was
gonna be excited to do right
um but again i'm scrambling
network's calling me like hey you gotta
you know throw something out there so i
did and i'm like boom okay there it goes
and i run back on the set
and now i'm working now that's out of
out of mind because i've got to be
present in the scene that i'm doing so
i'm not even thinking about it
i get back out to my trailer at a
certain point to check and make sure
that you know that went okay
and
it was like emails of like
congratulations text message of
congratulations and then it all just
kind of turned south
i was like and then and i had a long
text from jared and he was really bummed
out and i just i just remember my heart
just sank i was just like
[ __ ]
because he tweeted something right
well that
that kind of he's like this is news to
me no one even told me this right right
yeah i
you know
in hindsight like
that that could have been a a step that
was avoided but he did it and you know
it happened and we dealt with it and he
and i were
great like i mean that was right i was
brothers i wish he had just called me
and said
yo dude what the [ __ ] why don't you tell
me you're doing this and i would have
been like oh
okay yes yeah i i you know you're right
i
i've been on work i've been working and
this has been happening and
and
it's it's way early in the process it's
not even a done deal we don't even have
an outline
uh i just didn't want to talk about it
or tell people and jinx it
um and and he totally got it and he was
he's understood and he you know he was
like i probably shouldn't attack that
you know
like i was i was surrounded by people
and it was late night and
had a few drinks and i just i kind of
lashed out and so and i got it i was
like yeah look man i i don't your
feelings are valid yeah your feelings
are totally valid and i i messed up i
should have told you i should have at
least clued you in before the world
found out and that's on me
you